Tiffany is in Grand Rapids Michigan hi
Tiffany how are you I'm honestly doing
wonderful how are you better than I
deserve what's up to speak with you sir
my husband and I we are so close to
being the out of baby step two we're
just have our student loans paid off and
hopefully that by our one-year wedding
anniversary in May we have about twenty
six thousand left on them and then we
can start paying off the house now we
have an idea as to where we want to kind
of plan on for this next step my
question is my dad went through a
divorce and bankruptcy and he got all
the kids
Parent PLUS loans under his name and
this is something my husband and I feel
very strongly about helping him with
since I did stupid that and went to
university for five years and so we're
wondering first off we're in the baby
steps would we put that if it's not out
of bankruptcy until the fall so we're
not how sorry I should also preface he's
not wanting me to pay for all of them
and she's I don't want him to pay for
all of them it's about ninety four
thousand dollars in his name after all
this interest is accrued and how old are
you I'm 27 okay what is your household
income so this last year I think we made
about eighty we're hoping I'm
commission-based to make about one
thirty this next year since we both
started new jobs okay I think the story
I'm hearing and you correct me if I'm
wrong is that your mom and dad took out
loans to send you to college and then
they divorced and your dad got saddled
with them and my dad didn't he wanted to
help us out but my mom kind of
originally said hey if you don't do this
to help the kids I'm gonna leave you and
she did anyway but that's not the issue
the the issue that I'm willing to make
sure I've got clear is at no point in
the conversation before you went to
college or while your
College did you say these are my loans
they said we're going to take care of
our kids we're taking out loans to send
them to school I was a little bit
completely absent minded to the whole
fact that's not what I'm saying there
was no time that your dad said I'm
taking out these loans and you are
promising to pay me for them correct
that never happened no so I want to
clarify I don't mind you helping your
parents with their mess but this is
their mess okay you're 27 years old this
is your parents mess your parents made a
mess and I'm sorry they're in that and
I'll be happy to try to help your dad
any way I can but you're not in a
position to help him you're broke mm-hmm
and you just find it you just feel bad
for him
I really do I want to set you free from
that you didn't make this mess your dad
your dad and mom are a mess
their marriage was a mess their finances
were a mess they're a hot mess is that
right yes we're not mad at them but
they're a hot mess and you know you
don't you don't call you you know you're
27 year old kid doesn't come along and
clean up your hot mess when you're in
your 50s that's not how this works so
what I would tell you to do is maybe not
what you're going to do because you feel
so bound realest in this issue but I
would say that that you and your husband
need to get your financial act together
you need to get out of debt you need to
build your emergency fund you need to
start building wealth and some years
down the road not now for sure if you
have some extra money and you want to
give it to your dad in the name of this
issue that's fine but you guys need to
get out of debt get your life started
get an emergency fund buy a house and
save up a bunch of money and then if
you've got an extra 50 thousand bucks
and you just want to throw it your dad's
away and as a wink and a nod a tip of
the hat to say thanks for my education
that's okay but that you have you don't
have a moral obligation you sure as crud
don't have a legal obligation and you
know you don't have anything here except
just a guilt trip right and he was kind
of our idea going into it never brought
it up I just I guess I did feel bad on
one of our thoughts since we do have a
house we have about 60 left on that and
we have about 60 in equity we both want
to build our next home and paying cash
for it um we had contemplated selling
the house we both want to live in
downtown Rockford in Michigan it's as
beautiful just to experience it for a
year or two we thought about maybe
renting and then with the equity it
would pay off everything and it would
still have a nice chunk our downpayment
saved up for and we would just add on
sabbatical in that would be a good idea
as long as you're 100% debt-free you
have your emergency fund in place and
you are living your life properly and
extra money above all of that is what
you would help your dad with I am NOT
going to put the burden of cleaning up
their hot mess on a 27 year old daughter
that's just wrong if you want to do it
and you're healthy financially enough to
do it that's okay you're not today
though you're going to make some of the
moves where you're talking about or
thinking about to be able to do that you
need to get off this guilt trip you're
doing this with the wrong motivation
this is charity it's not obligation